HAPPENING WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE OUTWARDLY
DEMOCRATS AND UNITED IN THEIR
LOATHING FOR DONALD TRUMP.
BUT INSIDE THE PARTY, DEMOCRATS
MADE FACT HEAT EACH OTHER MORE.
EVEN MORE THAN THEY HATE TRUMP.
HOW VICIOUS AND CRAZY HAS THE
INFIGHTING WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY BECOME?
LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY.
LATE LAST WEEK, HILLARY CLINTON
PUBLICLY ACCUSED A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE OF BEING
A RUSSIAN AGENT.
WATCH.
>> I'M NOT MAKING ANY
PREDICTIONS, BUT I THINK THEY
GOT THERE I HAD SOMEBODY WHO'S
CURRENTLY IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY.
THEY ARE GROOMING HER TO BE THE
THIRD PARTY CANDIDATE.
HE'S A FAVORITE OF THE RUSSIANS.
>> Tucker: LATER A SPOKESMAN
CONFIRMED HILLARY WAS IN FACT
TALKING ABOUT TULSI GABBARD OF
HAWAII.
KEEP IN MIND THAT GABBARD IS A
SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
SHE IS AN IRAQ WAR VETERAN.
SHE'S CURRENTLY MAJOR IN THE
U.S. ARMY RESERVES AND YES
HILLARY SAID SHE'S A TRAITOR TO
THIS COUNTRY AND SHE'S NOT THE
ONLY ONE IN AMERICAN POLITICS
BETRAYING THE COUNTRY.
JILL STEIN TOO.
STEIN SPENT DECADES WORKING AS A
POSITION IN BOSTON BEFORE
EMBARKING ON A SECOND CAREER AS
A LEFT-WING ACTIVIST.
LAST CYCLE SHE RAN THE PRESIDENT
THAT INCLUDED A PLANT FOR THE
NEW DEAL, THE NORMAL LIST.
ACCORDING TO HARRY, JILL STEIN
IS ALSO A RUSSIAN AGENT.
>> THEY HAVE A BUNCH OF SITES
AND BOTS AND OTHER WAYS OF
SUPPORTING HER SO FAR.
IT'S ASSUMING JILL STEIN WILL
GIVE IT UP WHICH SHE MIGHT NOT
BECAUSE SHE'S ALSO A RUSSIAN
ACCENT.
SHE'S A RUSSIAN ASSET TOTALLY.
>> Tucker: STEIN IS ALSO A
RUSSIAN ASSET."
SHE ENTAILS THE GABBARD ARE
RUSSIAN ASSETS.
SOME ON THE LEFT ARE DENYING
HILLARY CLINTON SAID THAT.
SHE CERTAINLY DID SAY.
YOU JUST HEARD IT IN THE TAPE IS
ONLINE AND YOU CAN LISTEN FOR
YOURSELF.
AND THAT SHE KEPT GOING.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HILLARY CLINTON
EXPLAINED, IS BEING BLACKMAILED
BY VLADIMIR PUTIN HIMSELF.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S DREAM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT PUTIN HAS ON
HIM, WHETHER IT'S PERSONAL AND
FINANCIAL.
I ASSUME IT IS.
>> Tucker: IN CASE YOU'RE
TRYING TO KEEP TRACK AT HOME, IN
A SINGLE PODCAST,
HILLARY CLINTON ACCUSED THREE
SEPARATE PEOPLE, ONE TO HER
LEFT, WANT HER RIGHT, ONE WITHIN
HER OWN PARTY COME ALL BEING
RUSSIAN AGENTS.
SHE OFFERED PRECISELY NO
EVIDENCE FOR THESE CHARGES,
SERIOUS THOUGH THEY ARE.
THE ONE THING THAT ALL THREE OF
THESE PEOPLE HAVE IN COMMON IS
THAT AT ONE TIME OR ANOTHER,
THEY HAVE ALL OPPOSED
HILLARY CLINTON'S POLITICAL
ASPIRATIONS.
ACCORDING TO HILLARY, THAT MEANS
MY DEFINITION THEY ARE TRAITORS.
REMEMBER, AS YOU WATCH THIS,
THAT HILLARY CLINTON IS SUPPOSED
TO BE A VERY IMPRESSIVE PERSON.
HER FELLOW LIBERALS HAVE TOLD US
THAT SINCE SHE GRADUATED FROM
WELLESLEY COLLEGE MORE THAN 50
YEARS AGO AND THEN WENT ON TO
YOUR LAW SCHOOL FAMOUSLY AND
MARRIED BILL CLINTON.
SHE IS THEN AND IS NOW ONE OF
THE BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST.
SHE IS THE ADULT IN THE ROOM.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ALWAYS TELL
YOU.
YET NOW WE LEARNED THAT THEY
WERE LYING ABOUT HILLARY ALL
ALONG.
SHE NOT IMPRESSIVE.
SHE IS SILLY.
SHE'S RECKLESS.
SHE'S NOT EVEN VERY SMART.
LIKE DUMB PEOPLE EVERYWHERE,
SHE'S GOT A WEAKNESS FOR BIZARRE
CONSPIRACIES.
THAT'S THE REAL HILLARY CLINTON.
AND YET AMAZINGLY, HER FELLOW
LIBERALS ARE STILL DEMANDING
HER.
>> HILLARY HAS BEEN DEAD ON WITH
SO MANY THINGS.
SHE TOLD US ABOUT RUSSIA.
SHE TOLD US ABOUT THE PROBABLE
INTERFERENCE DURING THE DEBATES.
SHE WAS SECRETARY OF STATE.
SHE HAS DEEP KNOWLEDGE OF WORLD
ISSUES.
I THOUGHT WHERE IS THE LIE?
YOU HAVE ARE BEING TOUTED BY
PEOPLE LIKE FOX NEWS
PERSONALITIES LIKE
TUCKER CARLSON.
>> RUSSIA PROPAGANDA MACHINE HAS
BEEN PROPELLING HER, LIFTING HER
UP SINCE SHE ANNOUNCED HER
CANDIDACY.
>> SHE NEVER DENIED BEING A
RUSSIAN ASSETS.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT WAS THE ONE THING THAT WAS
MISSING FROM HER RESPONSE.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT WOULD BE
THE FIRST LINE OR TWO.
IT WAS NOT THERE.
>> TO YOUR POINT,
HILLARY CLINTON DIDN'T NAME
NAMES.
BUT IT -- YOU HAVE TULSI GABBARD
SANG ME, ME.
>> Tucker: SHE NEVER DENIED
BEING A RUSSIAN ASSETS.
THAT'S THE NEW STANDARD.
SO SHE MUST BE GUILTY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE TELLING YOU
ON MSNBC.
JULIAN CASTRO AS OF TONIGHT IS
STILL AN ACTUAL PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE ESSENTIALLY AGREED.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE CLINTON THAT
SHE COULD VERY WELL BE A RUSSIAN
ASSET?
>> I'M GOING TO FOCUS TO VAN MY
CAMPAIGN AND WHAT WE'RE DOING.
>> JUST TO CONFIRM, YOU'D YOU
DID NOT SAY NO.
YOU DIDN'T THINK TULSI GABBARD
COULD BE A RUSSIAN ASSETS.
>> I'M GOING TO LEAVE OTHERS TO
COMMENT ON THAT.
I HAVE NO COMMENT ON THAT.
>> AT THE VERY LEAST, DO YOU
THINK IT WAS APPROPRIATE FOR
HILLARY CLINTON TO INSERT
YOURSELF INTO THE ELECTION IN
THIS WAY?
TO GO I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR SECRETARY CLINTON.
I BELIEVE IT AT AT THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT A ROBOT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LIE, IT'S
NOT JUST DEMOCRATS HAVE GONE OFF
THE DEEP END.
REMEMBER EVAN McMULLEN, THE
GUY BUILT CHRIS TOLD CONVINCED
TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2016.
WE WERE TOLD THAT HE WAS A
SERIOUS, PRINCIPLED
CONSERVATIVE, LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE.
TURNS OUT HE AGREED WITH
HILLARY, HERE'S HIS TAKE ON ALL
THIS "I BELIEVE IT'S TRUE.
TULSI GABBARD IS WITH THE
RUSSIANS AND THE RUSSIANS ARE
WITH TULSI GABBARD.
SHE CONFIRMS IT EVERY TIME SHE
OPENS HER MOUTH."
AGAIN, NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER.
SO THEN TRUMP WAITED IN.
KEEP IN MIND TRUMP IS NOT ON THE
SAME SIDE AS TULSI GABBARD MUCH
LESS JILL STEIN BUT HE WAITED
AND THEY SAID NO, HE DIDN'T
THINK THAT TWO OF HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS WERE SPIES.
WELL, THE SENT WASHINGTON INTO
CONNECTIONS.
DAVID FROMM DECLARED THAT DENIAL
ITSELF PROVED CONSPIRACY.
"TRUMP LAST NIGHT DEFENDED JILL
STEIN AND TULSI GABBARD AGAINST
CHARGES OF RUSSIAN INFLUENCE.
HE WASN'T SUPPOSED TO DO THAT.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO PRETEND THEY
WERE NOT ALL ON THE SAME TEAM."
[LAUGHS]
SO IT WAS ALL SET UP, ACCORDING
TO DAVID FROM.
ISN'T TULSI GABBARD AT THE
SOVIET EMBASSY IN MEXICO CITY?
IT'S LUNACY BUT NOT ACCIDENTAL.
IT'S LUNACY AT THE SERVICE OF A
PURPOSE.
LAST FRIDAY WE HAD CONGRESSWOMAN
GABBARD ON THE SHOW AND SHE
EXPLAINED AS WELL AS ANYONE HAS.
WATCH.
I'VE NEVER HEARD ANYBODY AND
ENTER CLINTON'S LEVEL SAY
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> THE REASON WHY SHE'S DOING
THIS IS BECAUSE ULTIMATELY SHE
KNOWS THAT SHE CAN'T CONTROL ME.
AND THEN IF I'M ELECTED
PRESIDENT, IF I'M THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE AND ELECTED PRESIDENT,
SHE WON'T BE ABLE TO CONTROL ME.
SHE WANT THE ABLE TO MANIPULATE
ME.
SHE WON'T BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK FROM BEHIND THE CURTAINS TO
CONTINUE THESE REGIME CHANGE
WARS THAT HAVE BEEN SO COSTLY.
>> Tucker: IN OTHER WORDS,
IT'S ABOUT POWER THAT SHOULDN'T
BE SURPRISED TO YOU OR ME OR
ANYONE BECAUSE IN WASHINGTON,
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT POWER.
FOR GENERATIONS, A SMALL GROUP,
BIPARTISAN GROUP HAS LED THE
COUNTRY IN THE ROUNDED INTO THE
GROUND IF WE ARE BEING HONEST
ABOUT IT.
THEY'VE MISMANAGED THE ECONOMY
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED.
WASTED AMERICAN LIVES AND
POINTLESS WARS ABROAD.
THEY FORGE WEIRD AND IRRELEVANT
GENDER THEORY ON A BAFFLED
NATION.
WHILE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS DIED OF DRUG ODs AND
THEY PAID NO BONUS AT ALL TO
THAT.
THEY DIDN'T CARE.
WE'VE NEVER HAD A WORSE SET OF
LEADERS IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT THE DRAMAS ABOUT AND
THAT'S WITH THE VOLATILITY COMES
FROM BECAUSE OUR LEADERSHIP IS
TERRIBLE.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT THIS